bonjour une vidéo un peu particulière
parce qu'aujourd'hui je participe au
challenge
voyagez vous organisé par les aéroports
lyon dans la catégorie exciting j'ai
besoin de vous j'ai vraiment besoin de
vous d'un maximum de vue et de partage
pour pouvoir réaliser mon rêve et gagner
6000 euros qui me permettront de partir
à vegas pour aller couvrir le crs qui
aura lieu en janvier prochain
je vous explique tout la technologie est
au coeur de nos vies nos sociétés grandi
il voit naître de nouvelles avancées
grâce aux technologies depuis quelques
années nos modes de vie nos
comportements ont littéralement changé
grâce aux technologies qui aurait pu
imaginer il ya quelques temps que nous
soyons au temps connecté avec le monde
qui aurait pu croire que nous soyons
toujours plus proche est toujours mieux
informer la technologie nous offre tant
des moyens de communication à notre
sécurité d'une meilleure santé à des
vêtements connectés la technologie est
au coeur de tous elle permet également
des personnes amputées de courir à
nouveau l offre de l'espoir là où
certains n'ont plus la technologie fait
partie de notre histoire plus que
l'utilisateur attentif je veux la
raconter et partager ses plus belles
réussites
ces nouveaux espoirs la france a une
place de choix dans secteur
révolutionnaire la french tech brille
par son excellence qu'elle soit lyon
toulouse bordeaux montpellier
elle permet à la france de rayonner dans
le monde entier la french tech sera du 9
au 12 janvier 2018 au cs de las vegas
plus qu'un visiteur je veux raconter
cette nouvelle page de l'aventuré
technologique montrer au monde entier
comment la technologie va rendre le
monde meilleur et montrer comment deux
pays prend part à cette belle aventure
partager mon émerveillement devant des
technologies insoupçonnées permettez moi
de le faire en soutenant la candidature
au challenge voyage et vous je promets
de vous faire voyager dans un univers en
pleine révolution
celui des nouvelles technologies pour
m'aider partager ma vidéo avec un
maximum de personnes lâches et des
pousses bleus
commenté celui qui aura le plus de vues
sera sélectionné j'espère être
sélectionné et partager avec le monde
entier
ce que la france a de meilleur merci et
maintenant c'est à vous de jouer